[Music]
is gone highlight of my career highlight
of everything who would have thought
eight years later all you needed was an
Indian Channel and you can complete
anything thank you guys so much we made
history yet again guess what I'm doing
today guys that's right we're reviewing
moods yet again it's nice to see you
know that a channel finally has the
amount of subscribers that reflect the
content finally a channel that lives up
to his subscriber camp getting him to 70
million was nothing come on let's make
this happen
can we start YouTube rewind with
PewDiePie clapping and saying year
review oh how about that a funny
original idea for you to rewind I'm sure
they're gonna incorporate that of course
they are yeah that's definitely going to
happen I can't wait for you to rewind TV
series games 9000 subscribers in wait
what proving they use what so you had 91
thousand and he went to whoa is that
real when did this happen how do you get
nine thousand subscribers I mean I guess
it could it could be fake but I don't
know how do you get nine thousand
subscribers like that me checking every
day to make sure I wasn't automatically
subscribe 69 69 69 69 Tek a shoot six
nine please stop pretending like you
don't want to host me with you alright
it's not like you have anything better
to do that can she six nine I'm calling
you up big time it's time we need you to
review techniques your six nine means
it's for the greater good of the planet
do you not care about the environment
shake my head shaking and crying right
now I do
cashy step up and man up man this could
be very epic epic games it's time to
combine forces Felix
what if epic games teamed up with
PewDiePie to defeat t-series by creating
a custom Felix fortnight skin and the
only way you can get the skin is by
subscribing to PewDiePie
yes yes of course why wouldn't every
games agree to do that with me after me
trolling them for six months that I
don't want to play for tonight even
though I actually don't care I literally
own the reason I don't like fortnight's
because it's so popular I'm sure it's a
great game actually epic games that
would be epic listen anyone willing to
extend their helping hand I'll take it
I need all the help I can eat cuz I know
that together we are strong oh my god
yeah
people have been tweeting this to me it
legit when I saw it the first time first
of all we have so many goddamn spiders
in that office okay
there's so many spiders I have to kill
one at least every single day they're
nesting they're conspiring against me I
swear to God if they were t-series CIA
BOTS I wouldn't be surprised okay but I
saw and I'm like that's obviously just
like a little bit of I don't know string
coming out and then I check the shirt
and I'm like oh no oh no what if it's
still on me it could be anywhere
this is not a big man my first mean be
kind please he protect he attack but
most importantly he takes relief back
that's right everybody what can I say
I'm doing my part
that's right I do take my trollee back
and you best do as well this stupid
photo me and my sis saw the guy taking
photo of us
we were both laughing at him I didn't
think the photo would come out look what
you've done
people treat me like I'm some ancient
being that I'm some metaphysical being
that just exists on the Internet and you
know God forbid I I buy groceries what
that what is this now just stop this is
um this is actually bullying god damn it
I'm not a virgin ten subs in two years
five mil in six months three mil in 30
days it's actually more 9000 in one
second I mean explain that someone
explain that please I hope he does know
we are two completely different
Bangladesh promotes PDP pewdiepie Thanks
there's been so many articles about this
Bangladesh Beck's PewDiePie impacto
releasers despite him now I know it's a
country come on
of course Bangladesh it's a place where
Bangladesh where they have the the
11-hour flight Bangladesh which loves
cricket it has two large Bay in the
entire world how could I not know that
come on the fifth most populous country
in Asia
get out of here of course I know about
Bangladesh you had a freaking tiger
that's your country's national animal
how freaking cool is that
Bangladesh thank you for your service
very cool of course I know politics get
out of here let's get this epic victory
royale guys start YouTube rewind with
PewDiePie clapping saying new hero there
this again it's not gonna happen okay
don't worry about it dr. Phil we have a
situation here I'm white I'm black I'm
poppy Harlow well one of them is lying I
mean two of them is like okay I make
these videos making fun of these people
for having distorted worldviews Here I
am talking about conspiracy theories and
thinking I'm a female news anchor
population we are starving Soviet Union
sends dog to space population
make it in here that relatable moment
when your country sends a dog to space
YouTube algorithm 100 feet high sucks
and is gay
read description I'm not a PewDiePie
hater I'm a pro but how many youtubers I
figured if this would be a good way to
get views please understand I mean
pretty much you got it right there feel
free to call me suck some gay at any
time for views III give you the big
suction gay pass you yo graph and you
lose something he is the best youtuber
others think he is the best youtuber but
deep down we all know that Bangladesh is
not inside of India I know that I know
that stop it it's right next to it that
this sub right now P comedy Peter pie
goes outside LM o my friends are Peter
pie literally literally it's so crazy he
exists outside in the world literally
WTF I am freaking out right now
Peter pie is a person classic 9 yrs
Peter pie does normal human being step 9
your look uh what he's not renewing
memes
what are you doing I get that question
all the time what are you doing here I'm
buying groceries why the Freak are you
here 70 million you got dim right the
holy Oh God
sorry guys I only get one 9/11 joke a
year this is move on as quickly as
possible I have a restaurant in Mexico
I'm doing my part
thank you Mexico very cool can I do a
trump reference when I talk about Mexico
I can't tell anyway thank you facts
don't care about your memes it has to be
a pewdiepie related meme to post it on
pretty prized emissions where is that
written in the name cutie pie sebaceous
Wow
thank you for your peer if this video
gets 300,000 I will do a tick-tock video
did I actually say that I can't tell
anymore because you guys fake or Dacre
every one of them time to create a tick
tock account haha like so long it's
about time we have someone else [ __ ]
subscribe
every one just like that it's okay she
was nice afterwards okay she turned
around she realized afterwards it was an
afterthought that was necessary I'm
doing my part hello my real name is
Amanda I'm 21 female and really bored
looking for someone to talk to
how old are you 9 subscribe to PewDiePie
thank you very much I mean I hope this
says you know convince you to subscribe
to the channel
our hero everybody out goddammit I don't
know laughing at girls saying capital of
England is Russia Thanks you know what I
just said it as a joke okay it was just
a meme guys please someone made a
wallpaper showing the battle wallpaper
engine wait is this real okay why did I
have to be the small one you clearly got
this all wrong wait I got it I can I'm
gonna download this that's cool that's
really sick damn you guys are really
created big props man it sings so well
what is this there's so much think you
have been one when I'm through with you
we're gonna be completely [ __ ] let me
serve you [ __ ] lasagna
oh yeah lega description check it out
grinding what an angel absolute man
light thank you very much everybody was
so preoccupied with the 6-9 6-9 6-9 6-9
that we forgot how Pitt is actually
about to be the first channel to pass a
category in sense damn did I happen
already
screw your YouTube movies wait is there
any any other YouTube category YouTube
Sports YouTube sports huh I'm coming for
you YouTube sports you got nothing
you're no one
you're loser hi what is your name her
Monica me Hey whoa look at that
that's sake that's an amazing banner of
Brad and my Z inside oh that's great on
sleepy my drawers thank you that's
awesome I'm Jesus but I think you could
already tell so everyone I have an
announcement to make
stop bullying no I'm just kidding
what I actually need to tell you about
something very serious it's about
PewDiePie
you see PewDiePie needs your help in the
war against a series yes that's right
wand India taking over YouTube
okay I watch his Christian YouTube
channel
every day you know you should too so
what I need you to do is smash subscribe
to PewDiePie's channel or you know where
you're going oh now I'm gonna watch some
huh meme review to see you guys
well most of you guys hopefully not soon
thank you Jesus
very cool we are Jesus still on our side
absolutely incredible this is a track
that's a track it's plainly not showed
that she's a gamer okay I guess I was
wrong you know what I've learned my
lesson here never judge people but she's
not a video game okay I know that for a
fact she's not a video game prove me
that there is so many memes this week
honestly the reddit is like bigger than
it's ever been
Wow I seriously need to make like a two
part two just to go through it honestly
thank you guys
70 million times you know when Jake Paul
came out with this video I had just
moved out of my office I had taken a lot
of I took a lot of decisions to kind of
scale date down what I'm doing just get
back to the roots and do what I actually
enjoy doing and I felt really weird at
the time I didn't know what I was doing
and you know you see all these people
coming out of nowhere as well I honestly
thought like okay this is it for me but
whatever at least I'll do what I'm doing
but to see now all the undying support
that I'll be getting on this channel I'm
so lucky to be in this position I really
am so don't think I'm taking it for
granted I really appreciate it that's it
though that's all the butter you're
getting by
[Music]